"THE FIVE" IS NOW.
♪ ♪
>> Jesse: I'M JESSE WATTERS
WITH MARTHA MacCALLUM,
JUAN WILLIAMS JUAN WILLIAMS,
DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
FOX NEWS ALERT.
A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS TO TELL
YOU ABOUT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
RESIGNING AT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REQUEST.
THE PRESIDENT ALREADY NAMING
SESSIONS' CHIEF OF STAFF MATTHEW
WHITAKER IS ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SOURCES TELLING FOX NEWS
WHITAKER IS IN CHARGE OF
EVERYTHING AT THE DOJ, INCLUDING
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
THIS RESIGNATION FOLLOWS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEWS
CONFERENCE TODAY WHERE HE WAS
REPEATEDLY ASKED ABOUT SESSIONS
IN THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
>> Reporter: CAN YOU GIVE US
CLARITY, SERVER, ON YOUR
THINKING ABOUT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> President Trump: I WOULD
RATHER ANSWER THAT AT A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT TIME.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
I'M HAPPY WITH MOST OF MY
CABINET.
>> Reporter: DO YOU CONSIDER
REMOVING MR. MUELLER FROM HIS
POSITION?
>> President Trump: I COULD'VE
ENDED IT ANYTIME I WANTED.
I DIDN'T.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
>> Jesse: WILL HAVE A REACTION
TO THIS NEWS AND THE PRESIDENT'S
EPIC CLASH WITH THE MEDIA LATER
IN THE SHOW.
FIRST, THE HISTORIC MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
DEMOCRATS RETAKING THE HOUSE BY
REPUBLICANS MAKING KEY GAINS IN
THE SENATE.
PRESIDENT FROM CALLING THE A
MAJOR SUCCESS.
>> President Trump: CARLOS
CURBELO, MIKE COFFMAN.
TOO BAD, MIKE.
MIA LOVE GAVE ME NO LOVE AND SHE
LOST.
TOO BAD.
SORRY ABOUT THAT, MIA.
BARBARA COMSTOCK.
SHE COULD HAVE WON THAT RACE BUT
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE ANY
EMBRACE.
THOSE WITH SOME OF THE PEOPLE
THAT DECIDED FOR THEIR OWN
REASON NOT TO EMBRACE.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT
SLAMMING REPUBLICANS WHICH YOU
JUST SAW, WHO LOST FOR NOT
BACKING HIS AGENDA FULLY.
>> President Trump: I THOUGHT
IT WAS A VERY CLOSE TO A
COMPLETE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA CAMPAIGN VERY
HARD IN GEORGIA.
OPRAH WINFREY CAMPAIGNED VERY,
VERY HARD ALL OVER THE
TELEVISION.
I SAID THIS IS GOING TO BE
TOUGH.
I ONLY HAD ME.
THEN WE WENT TO FLORIDA.
THEY HAD CELEBRITIES ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
A MAN WHO HAPPENS TO BE A VERY
SMART PERSON WAS RUNNING.
RON DeSANTIS.
PEOPLE DIDN'T GIVE HIM A CHANCE,
AND I WENT AND WE HAD -- WE DID
SOME GREAT WORK.
>> Jesse: YOU LIKE HOW I SET
THOSE SOUND BITES UP, DIDN'T
YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IT WAS EXCELLENT.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY KNOWS I BASICALLY
NAILED MY PREDICTION THE NIGHT
BEFORE.
I SAID THE HOUSE, THE DEMOCRATS
WERE GOING TO PICK UP 20 TO 28
SEATS.
I SAID IN THE SENATE THEY WERE
GOING TO GAIN FOUR.
THEY GAINED THREE.
I AM BASICALLY A GENIUS.
GREG, BIG WINS FOR REPUBLICANS
IN THE SENATE AND KEY GOVERNOR
RACES BUT THEY DID LOSE THE
HOUSE.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK YOU
COULD GET A BETTER OUTCOME THAN
THIS FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I WANT TO SAY I AM KIDDING.
TODAY IT'S ABOUT TEACHING
LIBERALS A LESSON ABOUT LOSING.
NOBODY THIS MORNING WAS OUT
SETTING FIRE TO A CAR BECAUSE
THEY LOST THE HOUSE.
NO ONE WAS HITTING SOMEONE IN A
RESISTANT SHIRT IN THE FACE
BECAUSE THEY LOST THE HOUSE.
I WENT TO THE GYM.
THAT'S WHAT CONSERVATIVES DO.
THEY GET ON WITH THEIR LIVES.
I'M REALLY HAPPY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO SHARE
POWER.
I DON'T THINK -- THEY MAY NOT
FEEL THAT WAY BUT I THINK IT'S
GOOD FOR THEM TO HAVE A VOICE IN
GOVERNMENT AND GRANTED, IT'S THE
HOUSE.
I MEAN, WHO CARES.
BUT I THINK IT'S GOOD NEWS.
THE PEOPLE THAT WON AREN'T CRAZY
PROGRESSIVES.
IN THE SUBURBS, A LOT OF THEM
ARE VETERANS.
SOME THAT LOSS, BETO O'ROURKE,
AND OTHERS WERE PROGRESSIVE.
SO THAT'S GOOD.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE DEMS GET
THE HOUSE OF THE KIDS GET TO
PLAY WITH THE TOYS.
THE REPUBLICANS GET THE SENATE
SO THE ADULTS HANDLE THE HEAVY
MACHINERY.
CREATES A NEW STORY LINE FOR US
IN THE MEDIA.
IT'S LIKE YOUR FAVORITE SITCOM
GETTING A NEW NEIGHBOR.
NOW YOU HAVE A WHOLE NEW THING,
THE NEMESIS.
IT'S LIKE THE 6 MILLION DOLLAR
MAN WHEN THEY BROUGHT IN THE
BIONIC WOMAN.
IT'S GREAT.
MARTHA, YOU ARE STARING AT ME
LIKE I'M CRAZY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Martha: I WAS JUST SORT OF
WATCHING.
I AM ON THE SHOW NOW?
>> Jesse: MARTHA, YOU TOOK US
DOWN TO THE WIRE LAST NIGHT VERY
LATE.
YOU SAW IT RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE
UNTIL THE VERY END.
YOU DON'T SEEM TIRED.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE AWAY?
>> Martha: I THINK WE ENDED UP
WITH A MAP THAT LOOKS LIKE
AMERICA.
AMERICA IS VERY DIVIDED.
YOU HAVE A HOUSE THAT'S
DOMINATED BY THE DEMOCRATS, AND
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE THINGS
DRAMATICALLY.
THEY ARE ALREADY SORT OF
CHOMPING AT THE BIT TO GET THEIR
HANDS ON A NUMBER OF THESE
COMMITTEE LEADERSHIPS WHICH IS
GOING TO I THINK -- ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING THIS MORNING IS THAT
THE DAY AFTER THE ELECTION, IT
WAS SORT OF THE FEELING AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, YOU SORT OF HAVE THE
FEELING WOW, THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE OUTCOME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON SO I GUESS
IT'S THE NEW REALITY AND
EVERYONE IS GOING TO SORT OF
EXCEPTED AND THE COUNTRY MOVES
ON AND YOU SEE WHERE IT GOES
NEXT.
NO, IT WAS LIKE BAM, RIGHT OUT
OF THE GATE.
I FELT THAT WAY THIS MORNING AS
WELL, WATCHING THE PRESIDENT'S
NEWS CONFERENCE THIS AFTERNOON.
YOU FELT LIKE AFTER LAST NIGHT,
MAYBE THINGS SETTLE IN.
YOU HAVE DIVIDED GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS A VERY AMERICAN REALITY
SITUATION AND RIGHT OUT OF THE
GATE, WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLY
CONTENTIOUS, I KNOW WERE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT IT LATER BUT
INCREDIBLY CONTENTIOUS NEWS
CONFERENCE AND A VERY CLEAR NEW
REALITY IN AMERICA.
>> Jesse: LOOKING AT JUAN'S
FACE, HE DOESN'T SEEM AS HAPPY
AS I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE
CONSIDERING.
IT WAS NOT THE BLUE WAVE THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE PREDICTED, JUAN,
AND THERE WERE SOME WORRYING
SIGNS FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ABOUT GOING FORWARD IN 2020.
YOU DON'T SEEM THAT EXCITED
ABOUT RETAKING THE HOUSE.
>> Juan: TO ME, I LOVE THE
IDEA COME AS MARTHA WAS
SUGGESTING, A CHECK THAT THE
CONGRESS, THE HOUSE IS NOW A
CHECK ON THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE FOUNDING
FATHERS INTENDED.
I EMBRACE IT.
I THINK IT'S TERRIFIC.
RUTH REGARD TO THE BLUE WAVE, I
FEEL MORE LIKE I GOT
Ruth regard to the blue wave, I
PURPLE RAIN
[LAUGHTER]
BECAUSE I WAS SO DISAPPOINTED BY
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR,
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE FIRST BLACK
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA -- OR STACEY
ABRAMS.
I THINK LOTS OF DEMOCRATS WERE
HEAVILY EMOTIONALLY AS WELL OF
FINANCIALLY INVESTED IN BETO
O'ROURKE.
IN TEXAS, CAME CLOSE.
TO ME, IT WAS TERRIFIC IN TERMS
OF LOOKING AT THE HOUSE RACES.
AS I SAY, THE BIG NEWS IS THE
DEMOCRATS NOW CONTROL THE HOUSE.
WHEN GREG SAYS THAT'S REALLY
GOOD NEWS, I WAS PLEASED TO HEAR
MY FRIENDS SAY THAT.
BUT I THINK IT'S BIG NEWS IN
PART BECAUSE IT'S CHANGE THE
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE.
WE HAD ONE PARTY RULE IN OUR
COUNTRY FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS,
YOU NOW HAVE DEMOCRATS IN
POSITION NOT ONLY TO ACT AS THE
CHECKBOOK TO PARTICIPATE IN
TERMS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
IDEAS AND POLICIES, IN WAYS THAT
WE'VE GROWN UNACCUSTOMED TO.
I COME BACK TO THE IDEA THAT
WHEN WE HAVE SUCH A DIVIDED
COUNTRY, IT'S DANGEROUS.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
FEELINGS.
I'M DISAPPOINTED AND I WOULD
HAVE LIKED A STRONGER SORT OF
SIGNAL TO PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THE DIVISIVE
RHETORIC AND THE ANGER AND THE
KIND OF THINGS HE DOES.
YOU LOOK AT IT AND THE RESULTS
ARE THAT WOMEN, ESPECIALLY WHITE
WOMEN IN THE SUBURBS, WENT FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE INDEPENDENTS WENT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
IN RURAL AMERICA,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A VERY
SUCCESSFUL POLITICAL STRATEGY
WHICH IS I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
SUBURBS.
I ONLY CARE ABOUT MY BASE AND
I'M GOING OUT AND I'M GOING TO
TALK TO THE BIGGEST RED BASE AND
GIVE THEM CULTURE WARS AND
MIGRANT INVASIONS AND THEY
BOUGHT IT.
THAT'S A SHOCK.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT HAS A
LOT OF WORK TO DO IN THE
RUST BELT, PENNSYLVANIA,
WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN.
SOME WARNING SIGNS THERE.
AND IN THE SUBURBS.
IN HEALTH CARE PLAYED A MAJOR
ROLE IN THAT DEMOCRATS' VICTORY.
>> Dana: I WAS INTERESTED IN
THE DEEPENING DIVIDE, NOT JUST
PARTISAN, BUT GEOGRAPHICALLY.
RURAL AMERICA VERSUS URBAN
AMERICA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP, THERE IS
RED IN THE RURAL AREAS.
REPUBLICANS ARE SO STRONG THERE.
BUT IN THE CITIES, BIG MAJOR
POPULATION CENTERS INCLUDING IN
TEXAS, AUSTIN, SAN ANTONIO,
HOUSTON, DALLAS.
THOSE ARE GROWING CITIES THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
KEEP, I'M THINKING 20 YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD, YOU'VE GOT TO THINK
ABOUT IT.
REPUBLICANS USUALLY HAD WON THE
SUBURBS FOR A COUPLE DECADES.
TO SEE BACKGROUND TO DEMOCRATS
DEMOCRATS --
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK IT
SIGNALS?
IS IT MORE ABOUT THE PRESIDENTS
STYLE?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW
THINGS SHAKE OUT.
CERTAINLY HEALTH CARE IS A THING
BUT IN OUR VOTER ANALYSIS IT
SHOWS 50% OF PEOPLE WANT TO GO
SORT OF THE PROGRESSIVE WAY IN
50% OF THE PEOPLE LIKE THE
CONSERVATIVE WAY.
HOW DO YOU GET THOSE MINDS TO
COME TOGETHER?
>> Greg: YOU DON'T.
MAY BE DIVIDED GOVERNMENT
REDUCES THE DIVISIVENESS IN THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE, MY LIBERTARIAN
STREAK LIKES THE FACT THAT IT IS
SELF CANCELING.
IT'S GOOD.
>> Martha: ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
ABOUT DIVIDED GOVERNMENT IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT IS THAT IT DOESN'T
WORK.
WHAT WE SEE IS GRIDLOCK.
THE IDEAL SITUATIONS WHERE YOU
HAVE REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
BUT THEY FIND THINGS THEY AGREE
ON AND MOVE FORWARD ON.
>> Greg: I DON'T WANT THEM TO
MOVE FORWARD, THAT'S THE THING.
AS A LIBERTARIAN, I WANT THEM TO
BE STUCK IN THE MUD.
I AM PRO-GRIDLOCK.
>> Juan: MEN STILL VOTED
STRONGLY FOR TRUMP.
>> Greg: I CAN'T BELIEVE WOMEN
VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> Juan: WOMEN VOTED BY 20
POINTS FOR THE DEMOCRATS.